so in college
i was a government major which means i
had to write a lot of papers
now when a normal student writes a paper
they might spread the work out a little
like this
so you know
you get started maybe a little slowly
but you get enough done in the first
week that with some heavier days later
on
everything gets done and things stay
civil
and i would want to do that like that
that would be the plan i would uh i
would have it all ready to go but then
actually the paper would come along and
then i would kind of do this
and that would happen every single paper
but then came my 90 page senior thesis a
paper you're supposed to spend a year on
i knew for a paper like that my normal
workflow was not an option it was way
too big a project so i planned things
out and i decided it kind of had to go
something like this
this is how the year would go so i'd
start off light
and i'd bump it up in the middle months
and then at the end i would kick it up
into high gear it's like a little
staircase how hard could you just walk
up the stairs
no big deal right
but then funniest thing happened those
first few months
they came and went and i couldn't quite
do stuff so we had an awesome new
revised plan
and then
but then those middle months actually
went by
and i didn't really write words
and so we were here
and then two months turned into one
month which turned into two weeks and
one day i woke up
with three days until the deadline
still not having written a word and so i
did the only thing i could
i wrote 90 pages over 72 hours pulling
not one but two all-nighters humans are
not supposed to pull two all-nighters
sprinted across campus dove in slow
motion and got it in just at the
deadline i thought that was the end of
everything but a week later i get a call
it's the school
and they say is this tim urban and i say
yeah and they say we need to talk about
your thesis i say okay
and they say
it's the best one we've ever seen
[Applause]
that did not happen
it was a very
very bad thesis
i just
wanted to enjoy that one moment when all
of you thought this guy is amazing
no no it was very very bad
anyway today i'm a writer blogger guy i
write the blog wait but why and a couple
years ago i decided to write about
procrastination my behavior is always
perplexed the non-procrastinators around
me and i wanted to explain to the
non-procrastinators of the world
what goes on in the heads of
procrastinators and why we are the way
we are now i had a hypothesis that the
brains of procrastinators were actually
different than the brains of other
people
and to test this i found an mri lab that
actually let me scan both my brain and
the brain of a proven non-procrastinator
and i so i could compare them and i
actually brought them here to show you
today and i want you to take a look
carefully to see if you can notice a
difference and i know that if you're not
a trained brain expert it's not that
obvious but just take a look okay
so here's the brain of a
non-procrastinator
now
here's my brain
there is a difference
both brains have a rational decision
maker in them but the procrastinator's
brain also has an instant gratification
monkey now what does this mean for the
procrastinator well means everything's
fine until this happens
so the rational decision maker will make
the rational decision to do something
productive but the monkey doesn't like
that plan so he actually takes the wheel
and he says actually let's read the
entire wikipedia page of the nancy
kerrigan tanya harding scandal because i
just remembered that that happened
then
[Applause]
then we're going to go over to the
fridge we're going to see if there's
anything new in there since 10 minutes
ago
after that
we're going to go on a youtube spiral
that starts with videos of richard
feynman talking about magnets and ends
much much later with us watching
interviews with justin bieber's mom
all of that's gonna take a while so
we're not gonna really have room on the
schedule for any work today sorry
now what is going on here
the instant gratification monkey does
not seem like a guy you want behind the
wheel he lives entirely in the present
moment he has no memory of the past no
knowledge of the future he only cares
about two things easy and fun
now in the animal world
that works fine if you're a dog and you
spend your whole life doing nothing
other than easy and fun things you're a
huge success
and
to the monkey
humans are just another animal species
he has to keep well slept well fed and
propagating into the next generation
which in tribal times might have worked
okay but if you haven't noticed now
we're not in tribal times we're in an
advanced civilization and the monkey
does not know what that is which is why
we have another guy in our brain
the rational decision maker
who gives us the ability to do things no
other animal can do we can visualize the
future we can see the big picture we can
make long-term plans and he wants to
take all of that into account
and he wants to just have us do whatever
makes sense to be doing right now now
sometimes it makes sense to be doing
things that are easy and fun like when
you're having dinner or going to bed or
enjoying well-earned leisure time that's
why there's an overlap sometimes they
agree
but other times it makes much more sense
to be doing things that are harder and
less pleasant for the sake of the big
picture and that's when we have a
conflict
and for the procrastinator that conflict
tends to end a certain way every time
leaving him spending a lot of time in
this orange zone
an easy and fun place that's entirely
out of the make sense circle i call it
the dark playground
now
the dark playground is a place that all
of you procrastinators out there know
very well
it's where leisure activities happen at
times when leisure activities are not
supposed to be happening
the fun you have in the dark playground
isn't actually fun because it's
completely unearned and the air is
filled with guilt dread anxiety
self-hatred all those good
procrastinator feelings
and the question is in this situation
with the monkey behind the wheel how
does the procrastinator ever get himself
over here to this blue zone a less
pleasant place but where really
important things happen
well
turns out that the procrastinator has a
guardian angel someone who's always
looking down on him and watching over
him in his darkest moments someone
called the panic monster
now
the panic monster is dormant most of the
time
but he suddenly wakes up
anytime a deadline gets too close or
there's danger of public embarrassment a
career disaster or some other scary
consequence and importantly he's the
only thing that the monkey is terrified
of now
he became very relevant in my life
pretty recently
because people of ted reached out to me
about six months ago and invited me to
do a ted talk
[Applause]
now of course i said yes it's always
been a dream of mine to have done a ted
talk in the past
[Applause]
but in the middle of all this excitement
the rational decision maker seemed to
have something else in his mind he was
saying are we clear on what we just
accepted do we do we get
what's going to be now happening one day
in the future we need to sit down and
work on this right now and the monkey
said totally agree but also let's just
open google earth and let's zoom into
the bottom of india like 200 feet above
the ground we're going to scroll up for
two and a half hours until we get to the
top of the country so we can get a
better feel for india
so that's what we did that day
[Applause]
as six months turned into four and then
two and then one the people of ted
decided to release the speakers and i
opened up the website and there was my
face staring right back at me and guess
who woke up
so the panic monster starts losing his
mind and a few seconds later the whole
system's in mayhem
and the monkey who remember he's
terrified of the panic monster boom he's
up the tree
and finally finally the rational
decision maker can take the wheel and i
can start working on the talk now the
panic monster explains all kinds of
pretty insane procrastinated behavior
like how someone like me could spend two
weeks unable to start the opening
sentence of a paper
and then miraculously find the
unbelievable work ethic to stay up all
night and write eight pages
and this entire situation with the three
characters this is the procrastinator
system
it's not pretty but in the end
it works and this is what i decided to
write about on the blog just a couple
years ago now when i did
i was amazed by the response literally
thousands of emails came in from all
different kinds of people from all over
the world doing all different kinds of
things these were people who were nurses
and bankers and painters and engineers
and lots and lots of phd students
and they were all writing saying the
same thing i have this problem too but
what struck me was the contrast between
the light tone of the post
and the heaviness of these emails
these people
were writing with intense frustration
about what procrastination had done to
their lives about what this monkey had
done to them
and
i thought about this and i said if the
procrastinator system works then what's
going on why are all these people in
such a dark place well
turns out that there's two kinds of
procrastination
i've talked about today the examples
i've given they all have deadlines when
there's deadlines the effects of
procrastination are contained
to the short term because the panic
monster gets involved but there's a
second kind of procrastination that
happens in situations when there is no
deadline so if you want to have a career
you want to be a self-starter something
in the arts something
entrepreneurial there's no deadlines on
those things at first because nothing's
happening at first not until you've gone
out and done the hard work to get some
momentum to get things going there's
also all kinds of important things
outside of your career that don't
involve any deadlines like seeing your
family or exercising and taking care of
your health
working on your relationship or getting
out of a relationship that isn't working
now if
procrastinators only mechanism
of doing these hard things is the panic
monster that's a problem because in all
of these non-deadline situations
the panic monster doesn't show up he's
nothing to wake up for so the effects of
procrastination are not contained they
just extend outward forever
and it's this long-term kind of
procrastination
that's much less visible and much less
talked about than the funnier short-term
deadline-based kind it's usually
suffered quietly and privately
and it can be the source of a huge
amount of long-term unhappiness and
regrets
and i thought you know that's why these
people are emailing and that's why
they're in such a bad place
it's not that they're cramming for some
project it's that long-term
procrastination has made them feel like
a spectator at times in their own lives
you know the frustration was not that
they couldn't achieve their dreams is
that they weren't even able to start
chasing them
so
i
read these emails and i had a little bit
of an epiphany
that i don't think non-procrastinators
exist
that's right i think all of you are
procrastinators
now you might not all be a mess
like some of us
and some of you may have a healthy
relationship with deadlines but remember
the monkey's sneakiest trick is when the
deadlines aren't there
now i want to show you one last thing
i call this
a life calendar
that's one box for every week
of a 90-year life
that's not that many boxes especially
since
we've already used a bunch of those
so i think we need to all take a long
hard look at that calendar
we need to think about what we're really
procrastinating on because everyone is
procrastinating on something in life
we need to stay aware of the instant
gratification monkey
that's a job for all of us
and because there's not that many boxes
on there it's a job that should probably
start today well
maybe not today but
you know
sometime soon
thank you
you